hello everyone how's everyone doing if
you can't hear me if you can't see me if
the sound comes out wrong please let me
know in the comment section I'm gonna do
whatever I can to get it fixed if if
there is a problem
I always keep having some of these
technical problems I don't know why it's
a new camera but somehow you know when I
talk there was a vibration in my voice
located by the camera and I have no idea
why why does that okay
so let me know if there is any problem
with the voice especially I don't think
there's a problem at least for now with
the video but I've had problems with the
video as well so you know just notified
me in the comment section as most of you
know ons my dear son and partner here
he's in Argentina still he's going to be
there yes a couple months so he might
participate down then gang come in from
the other side of the world and join us
ask questions or whatever and as you all
know I was recently in a couple days ago
I was in a in an interview man from
Quebec I was interviewed on the issue of
the Rope model specifically to two
issues one of them is the what is
physics you know that we need physical
interpretations which is what I covered
in Buenos Aires and the other one was
the rope model itself you know you can
see it well you could say it went bad
the important thing was to get people to
be aware that
there's a competing theory that there is
a competing proposal specifically a
competing hypothesis hypothesis is it's
what we propose as a mediator for light
or also gravity also magnetism
electricity the whole works and so you
know when you have a new proposal
obviously that tends to wake people up
people say what do you mean a new
propose we have something new out there
because every day people hear just the
same thing over and over again they hear
black holes big bang dark matter
particles that travel backwards in time
time travel that your twin is much older
than you and that kind of thing and so
when you say look you know I've got
something different to offer now people
say what can you possibly have that's
different and all that so people are not
aware that there is a new theory a new
proposal out there and just to get it
out there is is a monster it's just it's
it's unbelievable how difficult that is
anyways I headed this interview was
divided in two one was what his face is
the other one the rope hypothesis and
today I'd like to talk a little bit
about the first part because we can't
seem to understand yet that but what
physics is about what is physics about
and that was essentially what I was
trying to get through it was not easy
and I want you to know that jfg this
followed John
jean-francois got he P I think that's
how you pronounce his name I'm not sure
everybody just calls him jfg and I'm
comfortable with that he's got a podcast
right out of Canada and well he told me
in advance before we went on lying on
alive he said you know I'm gonna play
devil's advocate and I said yeah
good you know do you be my guest beat me
up as best as you can because that's the
point the point is to put you on the
spot and to try to get you to answer the
hard questions and I like that that's
good I accept the challenge this so to
speak you know and there's a lot of
material to cover and and also many
assumptions that people have based on
their education based on their biases on
you know what they studied or what they
were taught in high school in college so
there's a lot of barriers to break down
and so it's not an easy conversation
when you have people with totally
different views on on the subject so
keep that in mind that's the concepts
that's that's what's out there anyways I
think jfg you represented quite well to
party line whether he was doing devil's
advocacy or actually presenting his own
point of view that's in my opinion in a
way irrelevant because we got to look at
the issues not what people believe in
and so the fact that he represented the
party line in many ways in many of these
questions I think was quite well it's it
was quite interesting and I think it
it's exactly what we need we need to
compare the rope model against what
quantum has against what relativity has
okay so the key question as I understand
it at least that's that was what was
important to me
the key question was you know do we need
objects to do physics can we do physics
without an object and this goes to my
what I call the golden principle of
physics I think it's a non-negotiable
principle okay that's where physics
starts do we need an object to do
physics and the way I look at it right
just this is my opinion religious people
will say that you don't because they
they have no problem doing physics with
you know with spirits they just want to
get a you know way with it look you know
all I need is
is to have some kind of description of
what's going on and that's sufficient
for most people they say you know I can
live without objects in fact that is
more or less the position or you can say
almost a definition of what religion is
that you have things done by miracles so
you don't really need an object God
sends a spirit whatever that spirit is
some force some energy and because of
that you know the the spirit the energy
creates some effects does something and
you don't know how he did it you call it
a miracle because you've never seen that
on earth you've never seen something
like that done in real life and so you
just call it a miracle and leave it at
that and say you know thank God that
God's watching over us and that he sends
it he spirits to do there is magic fine
and and those are the people who are
gonna say that you do not need an object
to do physics that's that's where it
starts and and that's more or less the
position that jfg took yesterday two
days ago he took a position and in fact
I'll read what he said because those
were the critical points and these are
things that we have to keep in mind and
he said the following he said think of
things like objects it does bring some
assumptions to talk of objects you are
already talking of a space in which
these objects are embedded and so not
everything in physics has to be objects
because objects are bound to be a kind
of subset of what the universe is about
if we are to talk about these objects
producing forces on each other then we
are really modeling how these objects
interact with each other in a space with
properties of speed of Newtonian
mechanics etc if we are to care about
how these objects spread across the
universe during the Big Bang from the
Big Bang to here then we need relativity
and we need these equations that bend
space-time it is clear that reality that
we
the reality that we invoke in physics
must invoke something else than an
object because physics is about
describing the universe in which these
objects can exist as part of a subset of
what can exist so here we have
everything that exists right and
concepts I guess or non objects are a
subset of what can exist and again then
has to do with the word exist I'm not
gonna get into that I'd like to talk
more about objects the point here is
he's saying that well you know you don't
really need you don't really need
objects you can do physics without some
objects because objects are just a
subset of what exists in the universe in
other words he's kind of saying that you
know we don't really need an object
because there's more than objects and
maybe we have concepts out there as well
like floating around I guess or or that
are of concern to a physicist because
we're talking again about physics so
it's like saying you know we don't
really need an object because you know
physicists can deal with concepts and
that's a subset of everything that's out
there in the universe okay so I insisted
and I said whoa no I mean if we remove
all the matter from the you know can we
do physics without objects and so he
clarified a little more he said the
following and this leads us to what we
need to understand here in this
discussion
in principle you could have a model that
explains objects without referring to
objects as anything other than a
secondary effect of that equation notice
he brings a word equation in there and I
think that's essentially what modern
physics theories are and there he is
right he is totally right there math and
the idea of objects is just a
manifestation if you look at quantum
Darwinism for example math and the
physical physics properties are an
emergent property of an underlying
system okay so yes I would say that we
can have physics that doesn't
we mention objects but we're objects and
visible atoms emerge as a consequence of
the properties that we give to lower
levels I guess we could call them lower
level objects they are not objects in
the sense of they could they could be
seen in the universe but they are
objects of the encompassing theory so
when quantum Darwinism says all right
there's a competing set of information
systems within the quantum universe and
as a consequence of this competing
service and entities there is an atom
emerging here or a particle emerging
there or when quantum field theory tells
you that this time and explains that in
terms of the activation of certain
fields or certain interaction between
certain fields I believe that those
theories are object less if you will but
that creates objects in the end and
again he's referring to the description
of mathematically description typically
through an equation of something that
happens or you know you put it in the
form of an equation and equation can
dispense with with the object you know
in fact I've got a very good example I
want you to think about this
you asked the Eskimo and you say why did
the sled end up in the one in the lake
and so he tells you he says well you
know my my husky pulled the sled and he
fell into the wild and just dragged the
sled with him you say what in et comes
over and says what's a husky he said was
a type of dog and each he insists and
what's a dog and the astronauts it was
so the dog is a four-legged animal blah
blah blah better yet he punched one of
his dogs and that's a husky
that's the type of dog I'm talking about
or he shows up a pictures that this is
is key so we've identified the object
what did the mathematicians do they do
something a little differently they say
look would pull the sled into the water
was mass and force what you have is not
a dog you replace the dog with thirty
pounds because that's what mass is for a
mathematician he doesn't see a dog he
sees thirty pounds and worse that 30
pounds is represented by a point so he
puts a point and he labels it 30 pounds
and he this as the dog the point the 30
pounds pulled on the sled that's how he
describes this whole thing of what
happened and is that cause can we say
that a point we 30 pounds pulled on a
sled does that make any sense is that an
explanation of what happened no the
reason he puts the point and he labels
it with 30 pounds or tells you that
weighs 30 pounds is because that's what
he can put in an equation and what is an
equation it's a description okay so
let's get this right we're replacing the
dog right with 30 pounds and we
pictorially represent that with a point
so we put a point we label it 30 pounds
and now we can use the 30 pounds in an
equation and we can explain why do we
need that what we need it because we
need to show what the force was you know
force equal of mass times acceleration
okay what's the force the force is just
what was needed to get the sled into the
water and for this he needs the mass you
need to know how fast it went so that's
the acceleration part but the point here
is he's not explaining the mechanism of
how the sled hadn't ended up in the
water he's describing because he's
trying to quantify the whole situation
you say
you need so much mass and so much
acceleration to create such a force
meaning to pull the sled into the water
so he's given you a mathematical
description when world what we're asking
how did the sled end up in the water
that's why he needs he absolutely needs
to replace the dog with a thirty pounds
and this is what they're doing that's
what they're doing across the board
they're doing that not only in this case
which is an obvious case but they're
doing that across the board they're
doing it with light do they tell you
what light is no because what are they
gonna let's assume light is a rope as as
I'm suggesting are they gonna put rope
into an equation
no what they're gonna put in equation is
little C they're gonna put three hundred
thousand kilometers per second a
constant or they'll just put the little
C and that's what they need they don't
even need the particles they don't need
the wave they don't need these objects
with which they we present light and
they don't believe in them anyway they
could care less because what they're
interested is in the mathematical or
quantitative relations on both sides of
the equal sign that's what they need so
they can't put a rope in there and
likewise you know if you have a magnet
attracting another they might go into
talk about gals if if they talk about an
electron they might talk about charge
you know one point six times ten to the
minus nineteen coulombs or so on you
know they're gonna put a value because
that's what they do that's their bread
and butter they deal with the equations
they deal with constants variables you
know numbers that's what they deal with
and so they can't put a little ball
assuming assuming in the electron
there's a little bead they can't put a
bead in there what are they I put a bead
in the equation and this is where the
problem is the problem is that because
they don't put they don't deal with
objects they've never defined objects
they never will define that an object
and the word object right and so the
question is whether we need objects to
do physics obviously we don't do need
them to do math which is what they do do
we need objects to do physics and for
this we have to define what physics is
and of course if like jf G's suggested
whether it was his own opinion or
whether he was just representing the
establishment or playing devil's
advocate he's saying that Mathematics
Physics essentially needs equations you
need to quantify things you need to
establish relations and if that's the
case yeah then physics is math math is
physics and everything is in perfect
order
but if physics is something else if
physics deals with a trying to explain
how a magnet by what mechanism a magnet
attracts another or how a pin fell to
the floor instead of to the ceiling you
know what caused it to fall to the floor
then we can can't use the math then we
need to replace all that math with
objects and for that the first step is
to define what an object is and that's
why no one has ever defined the word
object because they never needed it you
don't need it for math you don't need to
deal with the object themselves which is
what I'd say if - you're saying here we
do not need objects to do math we need
just to do physics and so the question
is is math the same thing as physics is
physics the same thing that's math and
what they've done the mathematicians
since the days of mm-hmm
at least the Scientific Revolution of
the 17th century is move ever more into
the realm of math because they could not
explain phenomena they could not explain
what electricity is they cannot explain
what light is or what the magnetism is
what gravity is all these unseen all
these invisible entities or phenomena
you know they just can't explain it
because in order to do so they would
have to try to make the invisible
visible they would have to show us what
physical are
invisible object mother nature's using
to cause such effects and since they
just kept doing math because they
thought they would reach an
understanding through math and because
they were also developing technology
rather than trying to do science trying
to get explanations they drifted little
by little ever more so into the
mathematical world and that's how we
arrived at mr. Max Born who said you
know physics quotations physics has
become more abstract what does he mean
what did he mean by that he meant that
we got farther and farther away from
physics we are doing abstractions not
physics and that's why we don't have an
answer for simple questions like how
does a magnet attract another or what
causes gravity and and the answer they
are these people give you today to the
layman who ask such questions
we're still investigating or they'll say
we'll never figure it out
because because of several things first
mother nature's too complex and or
they'll say that your mind a human mind
is not does not have the ability to
understand how this universe really
works the universe works differently
than our minds and we can only try to
comprehend it in our terms and the way
we comprehend it in our turns is through
math because math is objective we
created this language called mathematics
and from there we can understand it
quotation because again they cannot
explain you know something as simple as
gravity or magnetism so they cannot
explain the mechanism they cannot
explain the cause but they but they can
describe it and they call that
description science or they called that
description physics and I always quote
mr. Donald simonec he's emeritus
professor at Lock Haven University
Pennsylvania and he says unambiguously
he says science does not
explain science describes why did he say
that he says that because because
mathematics describes mathematics does
not explain so they equated math with
science and so when you ask someone you
know what is an object they say where
did that question come from why do we
need an object and yes you don't need an
object in math you need it in physics
you need it if you want to explain how a
magnet attracts another because you have
to identify that invisible entity that
forms what we call the magnetic field
you have to know what is twirling around
there something there's like James
Maxwell's so there's matter in motion
that's what a field is matter in motion
some exotic type of matter it's not your
everyday kind of matter it's not made of
atoms there's something moving in there
and he says you know we I don't know
what it is that's what Maxwell said you
just kept doing math and today we say
the same thing you know mathematicians
out there tell you the same thing
there's something in there
obviously someone might even say there's
nothing but those who say that there's
something in there they've never they've
always or they failed to identify what
that something is and they're not
interested in identifying again because
they do math and that's what we're at
with jfg here yeah let's see if I put it
back up there again so we can see what
he's saying you saying in principle you
could have a model that explains objects
without reverting to objects as anything
other than as then a secondary effect of
that equation so you're saying we don't
need to yob Jake where the object is
irrelevant because what we're trying to
figure out here is is understanding and
now I can't even say it's understand
describing what what happened so so
we're describing what happened we do
that with an equation and for that you
don't need an object you don't need the
dog to pull down the sled you can say
mass pulls on the sled and you're fine
with that as long as you say you know
the you know the the sled fell into the
water because there was a force that
pulled on
that force was caused by a mass that was
there right in this case the dog you
replace the dog with a point particle
you may weigh 30 pounds and you can say
see I can explain or describe really how
the sled ended up in the water and so he
so jf g continued so yes I would say
that we can have a physics that doesn't
specify that specifically mention
objects but we're objects and invisible
atoms emerge as a consequence of the
properties that we give to lower levels
and he calls those lower levels he said
that we could call them objects they are
not objects in the sense of they you
know them being able to be seen in the
universe but they are objects of the
encompassing theory in other words we're
talking about mathematical objects here
that's what he's referring to he's
saying that you know if you have an
equation and that equation is describing
something about objects but we don't
need the object itself because we're
interested not in the object but in the
equation and yes that's that's again
replacing the dog with mass and you're
saying look we're interested in how mass
behaves and not what the dog did that's
what's happening here and you know
that's that's where we stand today we
stand today and in this notion that we
can just get away with descriptions and
that's that's the serious problem it's a
serious problem because people have been
educated to think in those terms you get
a high school you go to a college that's
what they teach and they teach you you
know forget about the causes forget
about the mechanism that's philosophy so
don't bring it into into our world what
we're interested is learn the equation
because I'm gonna test you on Friday and
you better know how to calculate the
force and you're saying anyway I just
kind of wanted to know you know what the
Meccan
you know how the magician did the trick
not not the fact that he cut the lady in
half and he did it with ten strokes of
the soul and that took him ten seconds
you know I don't care about any of that
but that's what mathematicians care
about they describe everything in terms
of these values of these units that
they've created and that's their world
and and unfortunately these people are
in charge
publishing they have censorship power
and that's where we live in so I just
want you to understand the context of
what we're up against now if if there's
any consolation I was telling dear
monkey you know to check in today I
don't know if he has but anyways I'm
going to say the following there was a
gentleman who made the connection with
jfg and said look you know he contacted
me I think it was in October he says
would you like to be on this show on
this podcast and and talk about the rope
modeling and turns out he was also
wanting to talk about the nano-cells
about extinction other things we talked
a little bit about that with jfg before
the show and he liked that idea as well
in other words it was challenging for
him because he's got a different idea
about it it turns out you know when when
this guy contacted me in in October he
said you know would you like to be on
the show and I said look I got to go to
Argentina we've got a presentation
conference over there and when I get
back
sure no problem so he set it up for the
7th of December and it did materialize
we did have it and after the show it
turns out this same fella contacted me
said you know he thought we did great
you know I did grade or boat jfg and I
did great because he was part of the
show obvious fears Oh interviewer and he
says you know the show was food he liked
it and what he wants to do is he wants
to do a follow-up and the follow-up
consists in he wants to bring
a physicist he's putting out the word to
see if he can get a physicist to debate
and so we would pit not only again I
think we would have the same two
subjects we would have not only the rope
against quantum and general relativity
against mathematical physics in general
but I'm sure we would talk about the
foundations of physics what is physics
about and I don't know if it's going to
materialize I don't know if any
physicists will want to come
mathematical physicists will want to
come and debate something with which he
may not be so familiar with or where
we're gonna deal with a subject that he
says well you know that's not physics
he's gonna try to brush it aside that's
what's gonna happen for sure if it ever
happens if the show ever goes live but
if we could get there it would be an
interesting debate it would be an
interesting exchange you would see a
religion that perhaps is dying against a
new religion that's emerging so stay
tuned we'll find out if this if this
materializes if there is a debate that
could be quite interesting we're gonna
be you know clashing heads together you
know with this guy and it's not gonna be
it's not gonna be pretty
okay I guarantee in advance that gonna
be very pretty but the point is you know
I wish that would happen that we get
someone in and we get to debate them and
we get them to answer some of the tough
questions you know is physics about
objects is there a difference between
math and fizz is and if he concedes that
we do need objects to do experiments for
example I mean obviously you need it if
you experimentation is part of science
and physics is a part of science and you
need experiments in physics well
apparently you need an object to do to
carry out the experiment so as a minimum
you say well maybe
yeah as jf g here said you know maybe
the universe has more things than just
objects okay let's let's just concede
for the sake of argument do we ever need
an object in physics and the answer is
yes and fine that means that now you you
have not only the opportunity but you
have the duty the obligation to define
what an object is and that's where I
want to see them squirm I'm sure that
they're gonna have a tough time defining
what an object is so that's where we
stand
hopefully this follow up this debate
happens and if and when it does it's
gonna be very interesting and of course
I'm gonna publish something along those
lines for for the rational scientific
method on Facebook so that everybody can
come in and join and have a little fun
okay if there are no questions let's see
if there are any let me check that real
quick no questions I'll give you a one
minute here to come up with any
questions you might have and otherwise
I'll just add jerm for today and
continue tomorrow anyways to summarize
summarize the ONS is in South America
still gonna be there for a couple months
I had an interview with jfg French guy
really he's a Canadian guy but he speaks
French more fluently than English but I
like his accent I absolutely love his
accent and I think it went well because
despite that either play devil's
advocate or just presented his own
personal opinion irrelevant totally
irrelevant in either case he did present
the establishments questions and I think
I answered him pretty straightforward
you know I kept insisting on the fact
that physics does require an object
and I was able to present the rope model
of light just you know very very loosely
in other words just like an introduction
and he liked that by the way he said he
really enjoyed the the new model because
he said well it does give some
explanation stuff something to this and
if it's worth considering and then the
punchline is that maybe just maybe we
might get a physicist on line two to
debate me and that really would be
interesting so let's let's hope for the
best and see if it happens okay so stay
tuned I'm going to put something on on
Facebook if it ever happens okay so
we'll see you on Wednesday
see you that bye bye